well congratulations on my new addiction
oh thank you I'm serious I didn't know
what I was gonna get when I watched it
but I already am like okay I need to see
episode 2 I need to do I need to see
what's not you like okay do you have it
in you to say you're done you're fired
get out of here oh yeah yeah yeah I mean
it's panels is better at that sometimes
yeah but I do if it comes to a certain
point because I have to protect myself
yeah and I have to imagine though it is
like just opening a beach club is one
thing but going into it being Lindsay
Lohan knowing that you do like you say
have to protect your name and I'm sure
you have a little mistrust because
you've lived a bit of a life and you
know what what can happen yeah do you do
you feel weird at all or do you just
jump right in I didn't jump right in the
good thing was is that Athens is going
on five years now so and and so I was
able to see how it works so I wasn't
really jumping right in okay I already
kind of knew the lay of the land so I
felt very comfortable starting with
Mykonos and at the beach and in the
daytime and the light so it's happy and
and but I knew I knew the ropes at this
point so if I just randomly went there
with that are you there how hands-on are
you do I'm there you're there I'm there
but sometimes I'm in a corner it's a
wreck but I'm always there I mean I have
to also the staff the cooking the food
the teas all the details and what
everything looks like I want I'm a
perfectionist when it comes to that
there for that reason so that people
everyone feels comfortable and has a
good experience so I'm there are there
any aspects of it that you stay away
from it you like yeah no this is not my
area um not really
I tried up well yeah I'm not really
actually
sometimes I it's easier for me to have
panel students and dirty at work with
people and be the bad guy because good
at it yeah and I'm the nicer one I think
it's really mad at me for being so sweet
sometimes like he there was one point
where he was going
someone go and didn't tell me and it
really I was I was mad at him then yes
yeah because you know there's these
comparisons now with you and Lisa man
well she's inspiring he said I just saw
her actually did you yeah and and she's
a dear friend of mine so we're kind of
this is like the young baby version in
the junior version in a way but it's
true I mean I think that's a trans woman
yes lady and I and I really admired that
about her
have you asked her for any advice and
trying to do this and and really build
an empire I'll be asking her a lot more
now because this is the first time that
I'm even trying to figure out what to do
with the VIP hosts so that was kind of
difficult and confusing too because and
now I know now I know that they have to
be assigned specific things in different
tasks but this is we're just figuring it
out and it's the first year that the
beach house is open you're no stranger
to drama so how much drama will we see
this season on the show well a lot but
but for me it's it's the cameras flip so
I'm I'm kind of depicting how much drama
a little tell us they're in Mykonos it's
their first time in Mykonos coming from
America and so that in itself and enough
and they're on camera now so everybody's
different and I see that and I I
recognize that so you're building this
Empire which i think is really cool and
aspiring but you are the boss so if you
were to describe yourself in three words
as the boss what would you say focused
caring business what businesswoman all
right meet up here in a few can be tough
yeah and I like that but I do think that
you are very vulnerable does that
surprise you because one of the things
that that
saw when you got so emotional when you
were talking about your mom seen the
sign and they're proud she was what hit
you in that moment just how proud of me
she was it was just like wow I did I did
this I'm doing this and it's mine it was
great I mean it was incredible and I am
yeah of course I'm vulnerable
I have a kind heart and I'm sensitive so
I want it to be I want things to be
perfect and it was just a really great
feeling I felt really happy and just
grateful we see your family at all of
the show my my brother Michael yes he's
on it and his wife oh and some of my
good friends see that's fun I like
because - then we're seeing a side of
you that a lot of times we don't get to
see you know we get to see family we
don't get to see family Lindsey I love
the video of you taking video of your
sister Oh where's Eve house rise to
there I surprised her she was so shocked
it was great me and my little brother
surprised her she did a great job she
did a jerk how is your relationship now
with your family or is it good yeah
we're all good yeah we're all good
everybody's good been for a while yeah I
like that I like to hear that as long
coach with my family I love them and
they love when I'm here and I love when
they come to see me are you here now are
you where are you living
anybody you're oh you are oh yeah I've
been there a few years well on and off
cuz I'm I spend time in Athens - and
mikonos sounds rough where did you place
this access it me cuz I hear a little
bit of an accent where do you think you
picked it I think it's because
especially actresses even I think when
I'm around certain dialects it changes
each time with Panos even and it you
just you pick things up along the way
yeah and you've lived there for several
years so you know I didn't I do
sometimes I hear
like a little thicker x' maybe when
you're here and goes away a little bit
in New York or yeah they all started to
come back okay can we talk about my
favorite thing the dance hoho
don't be a bears just dancing that's
what's funny and and I would have never
thought that that would come out the way
it did because we were filming MTV and
they wouldn't let anyone leak that
footage so somebody that I know must
have done that oh my gosh enjoy it or
whatever that is the epitome of both
like great guys watching right we all
had fun that Dan and all the VIPs have
done so well we're having a pride party
and it was just just a really happy day
and then they dragged me up on stage and
you put me there is good music oh my
gosh okay
can you teach never good this is I'm
never gonna live this down can you teach
me cuz just the hair flip on its own
honey was everything no cuz I can't flip
my hair right now I like you shouldn't
be embarrassed because I feel yes I am
I'm like pushing right now but it was
like this sensation just an instant
sensation that just overtook everybody
and it was but they know until people
that already started talking about it
because also time difference was from
Dubai people were saying oh my god you
see your dance man
I saw your dances I'm like what are you
talking about and then all this stuff
came up and then Halloween people were
dressing in the silver and gentlemen
tell me you had a good last Busy
Philipps was great I loved that she did
that I liked that
- you were talking also in the in the
first episode about how you meditate
three times a day
mhm did you learn that from Oprah when
you did things with her where - where -
winter start publishing I was starting
before that but she really encouraged me
to keep doing that and that and really I
really find solace in it I wondered also
like what did you take from that
experience with her me we all want to
get close to her and everything yeah
everything being able to text her okay
so just a and you still text her no just
I just she's just a really kind warm
person and she really her heart is so
big yeah I took everything that she did
what did you learn from her what was the
best piece of advice she gave you that
you could take forward just to take care
of me hmm
cuz I have a tendency to put everyone
else first so and I forget hi I need to
take it me time yeah so that was a big
thing for me there are gonna be people
who watch this and say Lindsay Lohan is
opening a beach club a bar and she's had
struggles with sobriety did you think
about that going in or but that's that
was so in my past yeah and most of my
friends actually that own nightclubs and
stuff aren't drinkers or anything right
but no because I'm running the show so I
have to be on it and I love that I love
the multi I have to keep myself busy and
and I feel more fun to watch other
people have their own fun with what
they're doing there's no judgement in it
though there's nothing to do with my
past right when you look back to where
you've come from and where you are right
now what would you say the biggest
lessons that you learn
that make you who you are today I mean
we're always learning yeah so I couldn't
say one specific thing mm-hmm well my
mother always says you can't have a
testimony if you haven't been through a
test you know what I'm saying yeah but I
can relate to a lot of people yeah but a
lot of levels I think so and I even saw
that from especially a lot of the girls
were saying you know she's aspirational
and because of what she's accomplished
now and I looked to her and I wanna be
like that
they do which I thought was really nice
in Millington so when you hear those
women you see them looking up to you
what does that do
it's an honor because I can be in a
position to really help other people in
a lot of ways then that's a big honor
for me the ones my art you have because
you're doing this show now you've been
doing a lot of press again what's your
relationship like with the press now
it's just a let's I am not used to it
but now in this way it's it's um it's
great though it's nice it's a it's a
positive we're here for a positive thing
and I'm I couldn't be more thrilled to
be discussing it and bringing it to
America and doing something that I
haven't done in a while are you weary at
all of the media no from New York I did
everyone keeps forgetting I just I did a
show called sick note that's out so it's
not like I've stopped
um and just doing things differently
it's just because it's not to everyone
else's agenda I love acting that's never
gonna stop I'm always gonna act so are
you actively looking for projects or
yeah yeah you're not really gone from
Hollywood life you're still in the thick
of it you still want to act you know
would you consider moving back to
Hollywood no no not not move my life no
I wouldn't
I think you had liked having my private
life private that's important to me
which is why I love living in Dubai but
no there's a there's a movie called
frame that Nancy Brown is directing so
we're just raising funding for that
right now and then there's another book
called the honeymoon that I'm writing
the script with the writer so there's a
there's a few things I'm not trying to
like one thing other times how I think
the things well cuz this right now
you're multitasking a lot at what about
music my sister singing right now so I
really want to support her and that we
were just talking about this hey Chrissy
was came out I'm laughing so hard
because you were like a proud mama I was
lying on the stage like trying to get
the better so excited for her oh my gosh
I really I really was that person would
you elaborate and do something together
yeah we've talked about that yeah her
and I talked about that my song bossy is
the song for the show but that's
something we've talked about good um you
you do live outside of Hollywood but you
still have a Hollywood circle used to
have Hollywood friends yeah so who is
Julia have IDs to the beach like you
have a friend or two who would you
invite to the beach club to come hang
anybody who wants to come yeah I mean
someone specifically Oprah Oprah like
speaking it will have a good we'll do it
or not all filming day so there's nobody
you like that you would reach out to
maybe we'd see on the show there's some
musicians not this not disease um maybe
maybe okay yeah I'm definitely gonna I
want to invite some other musicians to
perform more people to do things for
next season when we think about building
an empire especially in the reality TV
genre
about the Kardashians do you look to
what they've built and say yeah that's a
blueprint and of what you want to
achieve I mean what they've done is
incredible
I don't always said this and I'll say it
again I don't compare myself to anyone I
don't like to do that or give myself a
certain expectation I was doing these
clubs anyway mm-hm and now we're filming
it so it's a great it's it's great for
me to show people that it's a fun place
to go to it's great for marketing and
branding right but I don't know what's
to come I'm gonna keep having the clubs
that's never gonna change and then maybe
venture out into other into the states
and open one here or we're talking they
want to do maybe a hotel and we can oh
so there's bigger parts to it I just
don't know where it's gonna go yet what
you do Beauty line or were you talking
about doing a beauty line I am yeah yeah
yeah details deep yeah well you're gonna
like you talk about it when it's
anything I just get it done yeah I hear
then discuss it I hear you yes that's
why it has this other Club for four and
a half years and then decided to do this
did we just I mean I I know I heard
about it but did we miss how successful
it was or they didn't really talk about
it here because it's more maybe it's cuz
it's in Europe some people wouldn't
necessarily think about it and not many
people were thinking of going to just
Athens to lohan cuz there it's bits big
mm-hmm maybe cuz I just didn't wasn't
promoting it here yeah but but it is it
wasn't ready yet
now you're ready she's ready um and you
are living in Dubai yes right now
do you have homes and other places or do
you just go visit well when I'm in
Greece I stay over there
but I don't have a place there right yet
are you really building it I
that's something in your eye that is
crazy
well I have the islands there they're
already the world islands
I'm just designing one there but that's
not come that's not yet that's gonna
take some time I mean I haven't come for
it I'm doing it but wrap your brain
around that with those Lohan Island that
was my idea
was I saw Athens was doing and then I
did the beach and okay I can do this
yeah so you build this Empire and you
you've got it and you're good don't you
want to have somebody to share it with I
share with my family
yeah I'm just done you mean I'm right
you know yeah
no but right now no too busy too busy I
just have I haven't I haven't had time
to think about it okay so haven't met
anyone like but if you're looking for a
partner what do you look what are you
looking for in a partner someone who's
hates the spotlight no it's seriously
someone who doesn't have Instagram like
a smart businessman yeah would you do a
dating app I would think I don't know I
don't think so no it's it is scary no
and so many people say it's the wave of
the future it's great for people that it
works for and that love it but no love
for me personally would you ever date a
celebrity again I don't know anyone
that's hit those like I don't know that
mark yeah yet no celeb crushes no really
do you want to settle down have a family
well yeah of course yeah yeah first I
wanna have a family and kids yeah yeah
this year marks the 15th anniversary of
Mean Girls 15 years my gosh 15 and when
I heard 20 years for Parent Trap I'm
like thank you for reminding me well
let's talk about both racing what's your
favorite member
of shoot 18 years 15 years see mingle
still to me feels like it was yesterday
I watched it twice over and I just saw
Jonathan Bennett so and we all kind of
keep in touch yeah to some extent well
Jonathan lacy they've all said they're
down there were I am - you are
oh it would be so much fun it would be
great if I don't make this hat I don't
know I don't know maybe we'll have to
like progestin I don't know 20 years
repaired trapped 20 years yes thanks
reminding me I know 32 okay I'm about to
blow your mind even more okay this is
your oh we can push play your very first
Oh goatee interview do you really want
to be a big big star super famous movie
star someday huh what about that appeals
to you excuse me what about that part of
it being a superstar appeals to you what
do you like about that it's just it's
fun and I like the attention and I don't
know I just I just I just like it it
seems cool still talk this handsome oh
my god when you look at that girl though
what would you tell her 20 years later
keep living in New York she's so cute
though this was your very first ET
interview before Parent Trap this was
when we were just being introduced
that's crazy
come on oh my gosh we're doing this
interview of course at serendipity 3c
didn't came here a serendipity in so
many years
you came here when you were a kid yeah
serendipity truly the the occurrence and
development of events by chance and a
half
or beneficial way what in your life has
been serendipitous this moment right now
yeah seriously yeah yeah um season two
we'll see let's see I hope everyone gets
through season one because it's there
there's a lot going on um we're hearing
rumors that your mom might be on
Celebrity Big Brother is that true